this morning a heartfelt reflection
thank you kirby thank you virgil
heartfelt reflection on going back to
school from our very own meg oliver
she's a mommy too her family faced a
series of challenges during this
pandemic including a year of online
schooling with three children in this
personal essay she looks back at the
heavy impact on her kids from being
isolated at home and away from their
friends that's tough as we enter a new
school year meg discovers a renewed
sense of hope and optimism
[Music]
i love the first day of school i love
the excitement the jitters making my
three kids pose for pictures even if
they're rolling their eyes we do it in
the same place every year under this
tree
[Music]
until last year when the rain kept us on
our porch
maybe a sign of what was to come
my kids like millions across the country
turned around and walked back inside
they would spend almost the entire year
learning remotely
as a journalist i brought you into my
home the first day of all remote in
2020. i've got cormac and maria here
logged into their online classes sorry
fred you ran into that wall there we
joked about it on the air meg looks like
you and husband john have it under
control right now
it's only 8 20.
this picture was from day two
a steady decline followed
my husband and i were both working from
home and we could barely keep up with
tech support school work and our own
jobs
i watched my daughter's mental health
take a nosedive
when a caring teacher asked if she was
okay i remember the tears streaming down
my face as i quickly emailed her asking
for help i turned down work assignments
that required me to quarantine away from
my home and in a hotel because i wasn't
sure my daughter would leave her room
i watched my son lose interest and log
on to youtube any chance he could get
well my youngest complained his eyes
hurt and he didn't have the typing
skills to keep up with the work
too many times the tears and frustration
erupted into yelling
my heart ached for essential workers who
left every day for a hospital or a
grocery store leaving their children at
home to navigate zoom and hopefully
remember to log on again after lunch
nationwide it's estimated up to 3
million children stopped attending
school or online classes after pandemic
shutdowns last year
across the country i spoke with many
parents and kids expressing helplessness
like jennifer valenzuela a mother of two
from california who worked three jobs
and was going back to school when the
pandemic hit
she told me she could barely get out of
bed in the morning when school pulls
down in march that wasn't distance
learning that was emergency learn we met
alicia nate olson from dallas the
parents of three children alicia was
forced to quit her job as a bus driver
for special needs kids to take care of
her own children her son has adhd 80d
and is bipolar it's so hard being a
parent right now because these kids
don't understand you can't go outside
and play with your friends and anisha
warner in new york city work never stops
work never stops an eighth grade teacher
and a single mom to her sixth grade son
i am everything i am his support system
i am his lunch lady i am his
i'm his teacher i am his best friend
right now
[Music]
despite all of the struggles and i know
my family
we were one of the lucky ones it was
much worse for so many others
but for my family the silver lining was
spending more time with our kids
and focusing on their well-being
even when we felt like we were drowning
this year most school districts are open
five days a week six hours a day i'm
hopeful this is a new beginning
my kids are excited to meet their
teacher see old friends make new ones
joke at lunch and learn after a long
year and a half apart it's time for
students teachers administrators and the
community to come together
and most of all as a parent
i can't wait to take that first day
picture
and kiss them goodbye
oh thank you meg oliver she says that
really doing that essay took her out of
her comfort zone but she is hoping that
families will be able to relate i can't
imagine what it's like to have three
little ones any kids at home doing
remark remote learning she said it
certainly took a toll but she thinks
it's important to talk about kids mental
health and now i think she said she's
walked her youngest for the seventh day
in a row to school and she's doing the
happy dance you know what i found that
was helpful for those who needed
assistance instead of asking hey how are
you doing yeah i would start to ask
parents is there anything that i can do
to help you and i got answers i was
going to say this how did they answer
that there were a bunch of parents that
live in deep jersey because i also live
in jersey and some parents that live in
new york they were coming to me and say
could our son stay over um it'd be great
if he can go in with you wake up with
you and go to school with your son and
before you knew it there's about five
kids that stayed with us for about two
months full house really reporting a ton
of food we're talking about teenagers
but you know what i felt good that i was
helping parents that might might need a
little assistance as they were full-time
workers and also parents that's nice
yeah no doubt about it